an unusually low profile weekend for
president Trump despite a new
development in the high-profile
impeachment inquiry lawyers for the
whistleblower who expressed concern
about the controversial phone call with
the Ukrainian president have now
confirmed on Twitter there is another
witness it said this government official
has first-hand knowledge and supports
the claims of the first whistleblower
the new witness is cooperating with the
intelligence community's Inspector
General in the rear we can
tweak'd president Trump dismissed the
news writing they are going to the bench
and another whistleblower is coming in
from the deep state keep them coming
but this weakens one leg of Donald
Trump's defense that the original
complaint was based on hearsay he asked
his Ukrainian counterpart to investigate
one of his political rivals to Abidin
during a call in July he insists he is
every right to ask another country to
examine wrongdoing involving Americans
but American law prohibits foreign
interference in presidential elections
the whistleblower claimed this was part
of a pattern of behavior where the
president used his political power to
push his personal agenda the White House
didn't provide anyone for the sunday
political talk shows to defend the
president in fact Republicans were thin
on the ground one who did make an
appearance insisted the president did
nothing wrong I'm not here defending the
president I'm not here to denounce him
either what I'm here is telling you my
my piece of the puzzle here giving you
my honest assessment of what I heard how
the president told me repeatedly in the
May 23rd Oval Office visit on the phone
and the 31st the reason he had very
legitimate concerns and reservation
about Ukraine is first corruption
generalizes endemic we all know that
Democrats are pushing ahead with
gathering more evidence this coming week
insisting it's important to get to the
bottom of the allegations
I'm deeply scared by the positioning
that Republicans have chosen to take
that interview was just a giant green
light to the President of the United
States to continue to solicit foreign
interference in US elections he
telegraphed that he's going to ask China
to do the same thing that he asked the
Ukrainians to do this week because
Republicans are allowing to are allowing
him to do
and this entire country should be scared
that at a moment when we need Patriots
what we are getting is blind partisan
loyalty public support for the
impeachment of President Trump is still
under 50% here's the worrying thing for
him though as more information comes out
that number is going up Allen Fisher al
Jazeera Washington